hello my name is Samuel Leeds and in
this video I just wanted to share a few
things about financial freedom and how
anyone can become financially free here
in the UK so I mean it's a real
sometimes people think financially free
means being really really rich actually
that's not the case at all financially
free simply means when you have enough
money that's coming in each and every
month regardless of whether you work or
not to cover your lifestyle which means
that you don't have to work it means you
can do what you want when you want with
who you want right now I'm just at the
park with my family and my daughter and
I'm not working but while I'm doing this
I'm still getting paid so how does that
work then well there's a lot of
different ways to create passive income
passive income is when you work once or
you do something wants and you get paid
forever active income is where you work
once and you get paid once and we're
programmed as children to work for
passive income we're programmed as
children to exchange our time for money
if you said to your parents when you're
younger oh I want this new thing or I
want the new Playstation that they'll
say go and get a job let's say go and
get some passive income so there's a lot
of different ways you can get passive
income you can do it through business
automated business you can do it through
franchises subscriptions vending
machines affiliate marketing network
marketing there's a whole bunch of ways
that you can get passive ongoing
residual income which means that you're
getting paid when you sleep but I think
the best way is property and I mean if
you look at the rich list everybody
who's super rich all invest in property
and there's a reason why they do that
because rich people are smart and rich
people know that the best way to make
money is to do it when you sleep and the
best format of doing that is to do it
through property here in the UK it's an
absolutely fantastic place to invest in
property because we're a small island on
overpopulation of people and we've got a
limited space Greenbelt we've got a
shortage of houses so despite what's
going on with brexit and the tax changes
and some of the people are you know a
bit scared at the moment property is
still the best way to create financial
freedom so I want to give you a
definition of what financial freedom is
a formula for those of you that like
formulas and like things to be very neat
and tidy and that is this passive when
your passive income is equal to or
greater than your living expenses so if
it costs you three thousand pounds a
month to live
then you need three thousand pounds a
month in passive income to be
financially free and there and the
fastest way to do that is to simplify
your expenditures as low as they can go
and then get that figure set it in your
brain and set out to earn that in
passive income and you can do that
through property you don't even have to
own the property you can control the
property you can use you can use
contracts like rent to rents where you
rent a property but then you sub rent it
out as serviced accommodation or an HMO
so there's you can do lease option
agreement where you buy a property now
but you pay for it later
and I believe that anybody can achieve
financial freedom and the best and
fastest way to do that is property I'd
love to know what you think I'd love to
know your thoughts so comment below if
you've got any experience in property if
you've got any different strategies to
financial freedom and left any thoughts
a comment below this YouTube channel by
the way we've got a lot of content
around property and how to make money in
property so be sure to subscribe to the
channel smash the like button and I hope
to see you on another video
god bless